it's a pleasure to be here I'm an
enormous fan of uh Pi data you know I've
used it so much over the years and to so
the opportunity to speak is is just
fantastic
um as we mentioned I'll be talking about
uh revolutionizing the Big Data age with
compute over data uh something that I
think is really an unspoken or under
invested in uh work in our space and I
think it's really transformative to the
problems that we're all facing today
so when I think about
um you know what the layout of the world
looks like it's really a lot like this
um you see the amount of data and
activity that's happening you know
literally every second it's enormous and
with all of that happening you're
generating an enormous amount of data
and that data is getting even more
substantial uh you can see here that um
you know based on some recent analysis
from IDC
um the amount of storage is reaching
into these zettabytes which is uh oh I
don't know about three orders of
magnitude larger than most people have
on their personal machine uh just
absolutely incredible amount of storage
will be out there and unfortunately
um you know a lot of people approach the
problem like this and say well I I don't
have a big data problem I have a bunch
of machines they sit in a rack they're
um you know collecting a whole bunch of
stuff and so that may be true uh for now
but the reality is a lot of people don't
think about how easy it is to generate
for example a hundred terabytes
so I I did some back of the envelope
math for this presentation and to
generate 100 terabytes in about 100 days
that could be any one of the following
it could be a thousand nodes Each of
which are generating you know one
gigabyte of logs a day which is not very
much it could be just a hundred VMS Each
of which have 10 services on them uh it
could be MySQL or your web server or
proxy or something like that generating
just 100 megabytes a day
um 20 000 users uploading five videos
each video is five minutes long that'll
get you to 100 terabytes uh a fleet of
10 000 Vehicles the average vehicle
today has 70 sensors on them uh and if
each one of those generate just 150
megabytes a day
um or let's say we're you're in a real
Edge scenario with temperature sensors
cameras so on and you have a million iot
devices in your entire fleet then you
just need to generate a megabyte of data
a day and you're already at 100
terabytes so generating it is quite
realistic for a lot of people
and the reason I mention 100 terabytes
is it takes an entire day using the
average cross-sectional bandwidth of an
AWS machine 10 gigabit to move 100
terabytes an entire day and if you're
once you get to generating this instead
of in 100 days but generating it in one
day
if you're moving that data and the
bandwidth hasn't dramatically improved
you're going to be facing immediate
backlogs
um uh and obviously that is not ideal
and I haven't even gotten to the cost
um you know if you build your own
on-prem data center with storage uh it
will cost you about 1.3 million bucks to
store that data over uh store that
petabyte over five years which is really
pretty significant you're talking about
real money at this point and again 100
petabyte or one petabyte is only 10 of
those uh 100 terabyte per day or 100
terabyte chunks so again very realistic
to get to and very very costly
um and that's if you have an on-prem
Data Center
now uh what I would argue then is that
both the time it takes to move it around
as well as the cost uh to move it to
some centralized location instead of
keeping it on those remote machines
isn't just recommended you know it's the
law
um so your options today are use one of
these many distributed clusters to
achieve this and spread your compute to
where the data is and there's nothing
wrong with these things and there are
many others as well but the reality is
that most data scientists most engineers
and most software Engineers don't really
want to use them they're perfectly fine
for high scale high throughput things
but they're definitely not designed for
you know really developing and building
your applications on top of
um you know just to use a trivial
example one of my favorite
um uh Pi data or uh uh you know Pi data
toolkits is pandas and you can see here
to to do the standard housing example in
pandas uh it takes literally you know
two lines of code to get a mean if you
want to do the same thing on Hadoop it's
this uh and it's not just this it's
actually you know even more than this
this is as much as I could fit into the
the thing uh one is obviously far more
approachable to achieve what you want
now I'm not dismissing what you're doing
on the right it's obviously a much much
higher scale problem the thing on the
left will not scale uh trivially to you
you know be embarrassingly parallel but
suffice to say as it stands right now
this is what we're presenting people uh
either do the thing on the left and have
very big hard drive on your local
machine
um or do the thing on the right
so then you might say okay but does this
need to be decentralized
well I you know in in writing this up I
kind of approached it like this you know
if you look at the dictionary definition
of decentralized it's organizations
whose activities are not performed in
one central place but may happen in many
different places
and my argument is that
these are already you know many machines
many devices many users and all of them
are decentralized none of these Exist by
and large in a single Data Center
the data is already decentralized and
it's up to us to figure out what we're
going to do about that
now you might ask well what what is an
example of what might happen here so on
the left we have our data scientists and
she wants to run a single large
processing job uh you had over the top
of these many clusters in this case I've
Just Whipped together three clusters
Each of which are writing to their local
machines
so she says she woo her one data
processing job she hands it to her
centralized uh cluster at that point the
cluster needs to download from each one
of those single machines assuming we
haven't pushed all that to a central
repository uh you know after that takes
that's time to download you know even
though it's being parallelized it's
still oftentimes going to Peg your uh
Ingress bandwidth uh but finally she can
start and she does and then she gets a
result back but oh no she got one thing
wrong and she has to start over and that
might mean re-downloading all of those
things again especially if there was any
time between when she rolled out that
job and when she actually executed on it
um because a lot of times that that
intermediate cash or that intermediate
download would be deleted uh because it
that the amount of cost and the amount
of space uh in that Central cluster
could be very constricted
so then you might say well okay
um there's this thing called the cloud
uh shouldn't I just use them and and you
know they'll take care of everything
they have unlimited scale uh and so on
and the answer is sort of
it's not like they aren't useful uh as
someone who you know worked at the
clouds I can say like we have a lot of
really good use cases for them but make
no mistake it is quite costly
um uh to store just store that one
petabyte of data on the cloud with no
discounts or you know special backroom
deals uh it's gonna be even more
expensive than storing on-prem uh even
assuming that you you know cut the
amount of uh admin you know by half uh
the storage price for anything that
isn't um just you know
um you know Glacier level of uh storage
is quite costly and we haven't even
gotten to the processing if you want to
process that and move that into a higher
tier of storage uh you're now going to
be paying you know roughly four times as
much so again this isn't to say there
aren't very specific and very useful
cases that these Cloud vendors can fill
in but making that the default for how
we do these very big data problems is
pretty substantial and we need to have a
solution that has a multi-tier approach
to this problem
so uh yes like I said I you know we need
to A system that maps to how we collect
and store data today
so how Tech can approve adapt to the Big
Data era well first like I said you're
going to have all of these decentralized
and distributed devices out there and
each one of those are going to have
their own amount of storage now again
they may not want to store you know
hundreds or you know thousands of runs
or files or things like that but they
can certainly store what they're already
downloading uh before they do a final
upload and so being able to execute in
that location is pretty profound and we
should figure out a way to do that
second is around incentive models so
this isn't just about you know can you
do things in a centralized way or
decentralized way but but really think
about it even more broadly than that uh
could there be a way for the the
ultimate clients uh to you know
basically contribute their own compute
or their own storage or whatever to
those uh to your eventual path and there
are lots of ways it doesn't just have to
be some kind of payment uh you could say
like you're joining an overall group of
people you're donating your stuff to
charity there are lots of things like
that and we need to figure out a way
that that doesn't involve everyone
filling out you know whatever a 1099 uh
in order to contribute their their
powerful Max uh or our PCS to the
problem and then third
we need a solution that is provably
secure and verifiable what do I mean by
that well
in this decentralized world you have a
realistic problem where things might be
um uh untrusted and by untrusted I don't
mean that someone is necessarily hacked
into your data center and
um you know has a virus on a machine so
that certainly happens but making sure
that number one the people who need
access to the data can run against it
can do so without for example exporting
everything to a CSV and dropping in an
S3 bucket or but second also that the
data that is running and the jobs that
are running on those machines are doing
it in a reliable and secure way that
that you know maybe you want to open
this up to allow your partners to run
code you want to be able to do that
securely isolate exactly what's going on
uh you want to make sure you're not
leaking data out the side door
um and so on there are lots of security
problems there there's also the
verifiability problem which is you know
I uh if you think about it you know this
is something that a lot of people who
maintain a small number of machines may
not have seen the ability for a fleet of
machines to get out of sync uh quickly
um happens all the time they could be uh
you know disconnected from the network
they could have the wrong version of a
driver because something didn't install
properly uh they could you know have a
particular architecture that you know
your your latest build doesn't support
and what happens there is not that the
thing you know the the best case
scenarios you attempt to run and it
gives you a very clear error that really
is the best case the nightmare scenario
is that you deploy your job to this
thing and it runs but it runs it in a
bad way it's got the wrong driver it's
got the wrong this it's got the wrong
that can't read uh yet it doesn't
respond with a clean error it responds
with an empty file or or even worse it
responds with something that's just
wrong
um and in the case where you're doing it
on on fifty a hundred a thousand
machines that's simply something you
cannot look at and discover that is
right or wrong because if you knew the
answer you wouldn't have run the job
distributed in the first place you need
a way to verify that the code you ran
ran correctly and can report back so all
of that together is what we're talking
about when we talk about compute over
Data Solutions
so how does this look
first we need a pipeline to declare a
job and a pipeline in a portable format
so if I'm running on an M1 Mac
um and I want to deploy this to a set of
arm or a x86 or some specific system on
a chip that uh you know my Hardware
vendor has provided I need to have this
thing be portable be able to run against
all those variety of types and so what
we need is something that absolutely you
know reproduces the job and the pipeline
that I have detailed and has a spec that
can be portable to any final location
second I need to be able to start that
job in any place including one which may
have a bad network connection or uh uh
you know unreliable or a heterogeneous
networking heterogeneous compute those
various problems and ensure that it
completes and if it fails halfway
through verify it and and Boot It Out of
boot it out or maybe rerun it or
whatever it is automatically and third
once it finishes I need to be able to
trust the results and that means we need
a network that is incentivized in some
way to complete the the job uh can't
just be volunteer it's got to be
something that that you know people chip
in uh but also the network needs to be
verifiable so even if there is an
untrusted thing or something that's out
of scope or out of uh add a version I'm
able to verify it automatically that the
system doesn't require me you know
manually walking over these things we
need a system that builds all three
together
and it can't require rewriting
everything as we saw in the other
distributed systems
um if it does require rewriting
everything I think you're going to have
a lot of really unhappy engineers and
data scientists and so on who are trying
to do this because instead of doing
their job they're going to be off
rewriting stuff
um uh you know into whatever version of
java that you know the thing requires
so how does this look when you build
against a compute over Data Network
well it looks you know here's the layout
that we saw before with our data
scientist or our developer overseeing
three networks and she has access to
this computer data Network so she says
the same thing she'd like to start her
one data processing job she hands that
to the network and I'll leave the what
the network is as an exercise to the
reader I'll talk about it a little bit
one example of many
but that's that Network then takes the
job and says okay here it is I have a
new job this job has a Content addressed
ID a unique hash that describes the the
nature of the job
um and it has three chunks and it offers
it up to the entire network
now node number one in data center one
says oh I have chunk number one I'll
take that
uh note number two says I have job
number I have chunk number two I'll take
that as well so off we go
now chunk three is on this node over
here but this node doesn't have any CPU
space and this one doesn't have the
third chunk of data but it does have CPU
to spare so what you need these two
nodes to automatically recognize that in
each other and pass the migrate the data
between the place where it is and the
final location instead of migrating all
three nodes back to Some central
location it's just migrating this third
one it finally migrates it over now this
node has both the the uh the CPU space
and the disk necessary and it can
execute we run the processing job in an
embarrassingly parallel way so all three
machines are executing simultaneously
and all three are now done and says
here's the content addressed ID of the
results
and then we have someone else in the
network step forward and say okay now
that you've done that I'm going to
verify the job and and execute a proof
to ensure that this was actually run and
the data is correct and you know
whatever criteria the original data
scientists or developer set up in order
to run that job
is able to take it and come back and so
they do they verify the job verification
done passes that back to our data
scientist and she says awesome and is
ready to go each node now downloads the
results not the original 100 terabytes
but whatever derivative might be
involved to that thing and she's able to
move on with her her work and again this
could just be the first step in a
multi-tier architecture where instead of
handing it back to our our developer she
instead puts it on a much more high
performance cluster to do additional
distributed things uh Hadoop or spark or
whatever uh using uh maybe she wants to
do training on it or things like that
so again it's not an either or there's
no question this step has to exist today
it basically only exists on one of those
platforms you saw earlier but I believe
that we need to build a more
decentralized Network that is able to
accommodate these things
when we do this with these Auto healing
auto repair and auto organizing system I
think you get a lot of benefit across
many vectors first it's much easier to
manage the network self-organizes it's
already compatible with existing tools
and has built-in verification which is
critical you know you don't have an
administrator uh being a gate to you
know a amount of time and so on that
that she has available second it's far
more cost effective it's kind of
serverless ish
um it's much more efficient at finding
the space in the Network that has
available CPU or disk uh and as you saw
much much reduced Ingress egress
obviously one of the highest costs for a
lot of folks but then finally it's much
more reproducible you can and uh
everything here is content addressed
everything here is collaborative you can
do a whole bunch of very powerful things
with reproduction because you know
exactly what it was you ran your job on
your data and so on and you're able to
um uh come back and and run it again or
not run it again because you know that
nothing has changed Additionally you can
build in a lot of metadata and lineage
tools which are super powerful
um something that we lack a lot of
particularly in the you know export to
CSV problem uh there's almost never
lineage around that
um but you can also get a lot of
communal funding models I touched on
like this is uh you could argue that
this is exactly what seti at home or
folding at home did originally they had
a centralized amount of data they passed
that to end users those end users were
able to run small processing jobs on
them and contribute back and they did
that in a communal way and that's
certainly something that we can do as
well
um so we have right now what we call a
compute over data working group uh
there's a link at the end that will show
you how to do it here you can see we
already have uh 15 people 16 people
excuse me
um oh 15 here but uh you'll see we have
actually added some since I put the
slide together
um uh on the computer for data working
group slide uh or a site we meet every
other week to talk about these things
um and you know that we're really
excited about joining together this
really isn't an either or thing or
really non-competitive we want to join
with everyone to build solutions for
this problem so you might say okay well
you showed me a bunch of people what's
the one true uh computer for data and
the truth is there really isn't one
um you know in addition to all those uh
folks that I showed earlier and the ones
that you just saw on the computer for
data thing what you have is the reality
of something like this where there's a
real
um a spread across these various compute
networks where you really have an
approach
um where you you make a choice between
privacy and verifiability and
performance and each job that you
approach may choose a different one of
these and each Network we expect will
fill in somewhere in this overall bucket
where maybe you choose higher privacy or
higher verifiability or performance but
you're gonna have to choose one sitting
right in the center uh you can but then
you don't get the uh you don't get the
optimization across any one of those
um and that that's really up to the
person to decide uh exactly what the
nature of their job is and how much they
want to pay and how long they want to
take to do it
um and really the options just start
there you know you really have other
things as well like we said you can have
incentive different incentive models
social Good Charity and so on
um you have segment different
segmentation models do you want to go
really broad to make this something that
anyone can use maybe you do it very
depth where it's you know very large
Enterprises who want to run this all
on-prem maybe it's a regulated industry
um or finally you know you have
different requirements maybe things need
to all stay within the boundaries of I
don't know Switzerland uh or you know
need to stay within HIPAA organizations
or something like that uh different
Hardware types or maybe you want to
select and say I only want to run this
on green computer for data Networks
so with that
um you know I'm proud to announce that
we do have one in market today uh this
is the the one that I'm running and
again this is just one of many out there
uh but I do want to talk about what we
have and um you know in my opinion it's
uh certainly a contribution to the
overall network uh we actually just hit
beta it's called Baka Yao uh which means
cod in Portuguese cod cod computer for
data that's the joke uh and um the idea
behind Baka Yao is to help provide one
of these things
um you can do any of a whole number of
things already on Baka yeah so in this
case what you see here is me executing a
python job on the back of Yao
distributed Network and you can see here
it's very very straightforward I just
type this word back to yeah I have to do
a quick installation which is pretty
straightforward and then I can run this
arbitrary Docker container from the
docker repo the this python executor and
say I'm run a python job and it's able
to do it I can also import a whole
series of files and do that as well
um or uh you know I can just hand it a
script and run that as well and so again
the idea here is that it's very very
portable I didn't have to learn anything
else other than potentially you know
adding a few words to the beginning of
my uh you know python script or excuse
me with my CLI that I would normally do
nothing else changes you can see here
everything else is just running exactly
as is
uh I can do r on it uh here I am using
an R script that uh I can upload and uh
off it goes
uh here I am doing pandas for example in
this case
um I have two files in my pandas
directory a python file and a CSV I'm
going to upload those to ipfs that's the
free globally distributed ipfs Network
which store you know has more than 18
exabytes of space on it uh so I'll
upload that there and then I can just
run that job and in that I'm going to
use pandas to read that csvn and uh
print out you know a series of
transactions and I do that there so
again no translation I didn't have to
you know rewrite my script I didn't have
to do anything I'm just magically using
a decentralized network
uh maybe I want to use duckdb this is a
crazy cool example where um duckdb is uh
an enormous amount of flexibility and
usage a whole bunch of different people
are using it out there
to use arbitrary SQL queries against a
um a parquet file or excuse me any flat
uh columnar file and you can see here
I'm just doing select count from Yellow
Taxi parquet
um and there I am I can you see I've run
that job uh on a you know maybe it's a
much larger machine than I have access
to just you know an eight GPU machine
with 8C uh G gigabytes of RAM
I can here I'm going to do inference
against YOLO and here you can see I'm
just running it against an arbitrary
image here I could run it against
whatever 10 000 images uh all on these
remote machines and uh it's ready to go
um I can also do it uh build Alpha fold
so here you go right um using Docker run
I do it against a single GPU machine
here's all the weights and the databases
uh and I hand it uh hand it off and run
it and Presto I'm I'm now running Alpha
fold
um again I didn't have to download
anything this is a two and a half
terabyte Alpha full database that I
didn't have to spend my time downloading
I just ran it on the system that was
already hosted out there and uh off it
went
and you might ask is this a
cryptocurrency thing
and I promise you no it is not uh while
cryptocurrency uh and you know overall
um uh cryptography is key to our system
um all these machines and things today
are things that we already support uh
and uh today require no
um you know interaction with
cryptocurrency in any way now that said
we know the web 3 Community is very
interested in this and we will certainly
give them a great home here uh to do a
whole bunch of different installations
and jobs against it but the truth is we
want to transform data processing by
giving developers simple low-cost
distributed first tools that unlock a
collaborative ecosystem we will help
cryptocurrency and web three people
achieve that but we will also help web
one and web 2 people as well because it
is critical that if we're going to make
progress against this very fundamental
problem we have to support all comers
and I can't stress enough that that we
are more than open to working with
anyone
and with that uh I will wrap up uh I
actually don't know if I can take
questions but um here you can see a
whole bunch of stuff you can also see
some QR codes in the upper right corner
um you're more than welcome to uh you
know scan those and uh jump over uh
they'll link to things that are on the
slide and so on uh but we'd love to hear
from you and love to see if we can
support you uh in the near future